Ich finde, die Diskussion wirkt so
ein bisschen, als wenn wir gerade darüber
entscheiden, ob wir neu in die Atomenergie
für die nächsten 200 Jahre einsteigen.
Der Atommüll ist da, das ist ein Problem,
das es gibt und ich glaube
das der Diskussionspunkt eher ist:
Streiten wir uns über 10 Jahre weiter
Atommüll oder streiten
wir uns über 1,5 Grad?
Hallo und herzlich willkommen
bei 13 Fragen, wir starten direkt
mit der Konfliktfrage: Ist der deutsche
Atomausstieg ein Fehler? Wenn ihr sagt Ja,
der ist ein Riesenfehler sogar,
dann geht ihr bitte auf das grüne Feld.
Wenn ihr sagt Nein, der Ausstieg ist
genau richtig so. Je schneller, desto besser,
dann geht ihr jetzt bitte aufs gelbe
Feld. Ihr könnt euch jetzt gerne positionieren.
Zu gefährlich, zu umweltschädlich,
zu teuer. Nach der Atomkatastrophe
in Fukushima im Jahr 2011 ist der Atomausstieg
in Deutschland beschlossene
Sache. Ende 2022 soll nun das letzte
Atomkraftwerk bei uns vom Netz gehen.
Endlich jubeln die einen, die teilweise
jahrzehntelang gegen Atomkraft
in Deutschland protestiert
haben. Aber warum denn gerade jetzt? Sagen
die anderen, die wie die meisten
europäischen Länder davon überzeugt sind:
Nur mit Atomkraft können wir das Klima
retten. Und kürzlich attestierte dann
auch noch die EU-Kommission:
Atomenergie ist grün. Zumindest so lange wir nicht
genug erneuerbare Energien haben.
Meine Gäste bei 13 Fragen sind sich uneinig,
aber wir sind ja auch hier, um einen
Kompromiss zu finden. Und ich bin wirklich
sehr gespannt, ob sich die beiden
Seiten heute ein bisschen aufeinander zubewegen
werden. Denn eins ist klar: Alle
Menschen, die hier heute auf dem Spielfeld stehen,
die wollen den Klimawandel stoppen.
Die Frage ist nur, wie? Deswegen die Frage
an euch mit Atomenergie oder ohne?
Wo würdet ihr dann auf dem Feld stehen?
Bei Grün? Ja, der deutsche Atomausstieg
ist ein Riesenfehler. Oder bei Gelb. Nein,
der ist genau richtig so und soll bitte
so schnell es geht passieren. Und für euch,
meine Gäste, gilt ab jetzt: Wenn ihr der anderen
Seite in einem Argument zustimmt,
dann könnt ihr einen Schritt auf sie zugehen.
Und wenn euch etwas aufregt,
ein Argument, eine Aussage, was auch immer,
dann könnt ihr auch das gerne
mit einer Bewegung verdeutlichen, indem ihr einen
Schritt nach hinten geht. Alina,
ich möchte mit dir anfangen. Ich glaube,
bei vielen von uns haben sich die Bilder
aus Tschernobyl wahrscheinlich für immer
eingeprägt. Vor allem durch die Medien,
durch Serien, durch Fotos. Wie ist das für dich?
Woran denkst du, wenn du Tschernobyl
hörst? Du hast ja auch einen ganz
persönlichen Bezug dazu. Also tatsächlich,
Tschernobyl ist eine Familiengeschichte
für mich. Ich bin selber aus Tschernobyl
evakuiert und mein Vater hat in der Nacht
das GAUs im Tschernobyl Kraftwerk
gearbeitet und auch Jahre
später ist er an den Nachwirkungen
der Tschernobyl-Katastrophe
gestorben. Trotz meines persönlichen Bezugs
zu Tschernobyl, bin ich generell gegen den deutschen
Ausstieg aus dem Atomprogramm.
Ich glaube, dass Atomenergie viel
grüner und zuverlässiger ist, als viele denken.
Und ich glaube auch, dass es eine populistische
und zu frühe Entscheidung
von der deutscher Regierung war. Du
stehst wahrscheinlich auf der Seite des Feldes,
wo einige sich drüber wundern würden.
Magst du das noch mal erklären, warum du
da stehst und nicht auf der gelben
Seite? Also ich verstehe das was passiert ist,
denn Tschernobyl ist ein riesige
Katastrophe und wie gesagt, meine Familie
wurde dann dadurch direkt
beeinflusst. Andererseits bin ich eine Realistin.
Ich kann sehen, wie statistisch
manche Sachen passieren oder nicht passieren,
wie gefährlich irgendwas ist im Vergleich
zu andereren Sachen und in der Realität
ist es einer von sichersten
Energiequellen, was es heutzutage gibt.
Hier bewegen sich schon ein paar
Leute nach hinten. Cecile, du hast dich
auch ein bisschen nach hinten
bewegt. Kannst du verstehen, warum Alina
auf der auf der grünen
Seite des Feldes steht?
Alina hat gesagt, sie ist Realistin.
Aber ich finde Realist sein, ist einfach
anzuerkennen, dass die Technologie
zu gefährlich ist. Und zwar nicht
nur wegen GAU-Gefahr und Tschernobyl.
Man sagt ja, das war anders, das war
die Sovietunion, dann sagt man bei Fukushima:
Ja, da gab es einen Tsunami.
Also ich selbst komme aus Frankreich
und bei Bordeaux hat es vor 20 Jahren
zum Beispiel eine beinahe Katastrophe
gegeben, weil gleichzeitig ein Sturm war
und eine Überschwemmung von der gesamten
elektronischen Anlage, die das AKW
steuert. Wir waren sehr knapp an einem
Unfall. Wie oft muss das noch passieren?
Das Thema Atomkraft liegt mir am Herzen,
weil es einfach um das Klima
und um unsere Lebensgrundlage geht.
Wenn wir die zerstören, können wir nicht
weiterleben. Und bei Atomkraft spielt
sehr viel eine Rolle. Es gibt die atomare
Verseuchung, die natürlich ein Problem
ist, aber auch geopolitisch. Wir leben
in einer instabilen Welt. Ich meine,
jetzt gerade hören wir gerade von der Ukraine
und die Interessen Russlands.
Russland ist eine Atommacht. Das ist nicht
ungefährlich. Also für mich können
wir diese Gefahren nicht verantworten.
Elia du bist auch einen kleinen Schritt
nach hinten gegangen. Warum? Also ich habe
mich gerade vor allem auch an dem "Das
wäre eine sichere Energiequelle" gestoßen,
weil ich dachte, es gibt Alternativen,
die sind auf jeden Fall sicherer: erneuerbare
Energien. Und wenn Menschen sagen
Atomenergie ist super, sicher und super
toll, dann wird dabei vor allem auch der Uranabbau
ausgeblendet, wo große Teile
von der Natur zerstört werden und wo Krankheiten
in den Anbaugebieten immens
in die Höhe gehen. Krankheiten wie Krebs,
Leukämie und so weiter. Und der Protest,
der an diesen Orten
stattfindet, der wird komplett ignoriert.
Das für die Atomenergiegewinnung
notwendige Uran wird vor allem in Ländern
des globalen Südens und auf dem Territorium
von indigenen Gemeinschaften
abgebaut. Menschen, die an Atomkraft
festhalten, blenden sowohl die kolonialen
Kontinuitäten als auch die gesundheitliche
Gefährdung, die mit der Nutzung
von Atomkraftwerken einhergeht,
aus. Yasmine ist einen Schritt auf Elia
-zu gegangen. Warum?
-Ich glaube, das ist genau der Knackpunkt.
Es geht hier glaube ich gar nicht
darum zu sagen, dass Atomkraft die mit Abstand
beste Lösung dafür ist, wie wir unseren
Strom versichern. Aber ich glaube,
der Zeitpunkt zu diskutieren, was ist
richtig und was falsch, ist halt
die falsche Diskussion. Für mich
gibt es nicht die perfekte Lösung
für die Energiewende, weil ich glaube,
dass wir zu viele Fehler
in der Vergangenheit gemacht
haben. Zum Beispiel sind wir zu früh
aus der Atomenergie ausgestiegen und haben
auch Debatten falsch geführt. Das heißt,
am Ende starten wir nicht von neu,
sondern müssen jetzt mit Kompromissen arbeiten.
Es ist, glaube ich, außer Frage,
dass Strahlung und dass Atomkraftwerke
ein gewisses Risiko haben, aber auch rein
wissenschaftlich in den letzten Jahren
durchaus klar ist, dass Atomkraftwerke
ein gewisses Risiko haben,
das der einschätzbar ist und da viel
Kontrolle erfolgt, also von den Leuten,
die daran arbeiten, den Werten,
die täglich gemessen werden, bis hin
zu der Entsorgung und den Prozess und wer
davon betroffen ist. Es sind also keine
verdeckten Prozesse und ich glaube,
da muss man andocken zu sagen, wie viel
Risiko nimmt man in Kauf und was sind
die Kosten davon, wenn man das jetzt sofort
-abschaltet. Was passiert dann?
-Also ich finde, hier muss man sich schon
auch fragen, wo werden denn die Risiken
in Kauf genommen? Und in Deutschland gibt
es Uranvorkommen und in Deutschland
wird Uran nicht abgebaut, weil es extreme
gesundheitliche Schäden nach sich
zieht und weil dadurch die Natur zerstört wird.
Und hier werden halt die negativen
Folgen von Uranabbau von der Atomindustrie
ausgelagert, vor allem in den globalen
Süden. Also es geht darum, was ist richtig
und was falsch und geht
es auch um Menschenrechte.
Das ist auch wieder eine sehr eurozentrische,
aktivistische Sicht.
Denn es ist durchaus etwas, was auch in anderen
Kontinenten, sowohl im asiatischen
Raum als auch in amerikanisch und südamerikanischen
Raum auch ausgebaut
wird. Jetzt zu sagen, dass man das rein
darauf runterbrechen kann, dass Europa
seinen Atommüll oder die Schäden
davon nur der globale Süden trägt, ist ja
auch ein Gegenargument automatisch.
Weil wenn wir hier weiter auf Atomenergie
setzen würden, wir keine 1,5 Grad
Risiken mehr hätten, dann würde der globale Süden
jetzt auch nicht schon so unter der Klimakrise
leiden, wie er es tut.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Teufelskreis,
wo es nicht darum geht, was ist richtig
und was falsch, sondern was sind die nächsten
Schritte, um den nächsten zehn
-Jahren also 1,5 Grad zu schaffen?
-Also ich denke, wir sind hier in einer Art
deutschsprachigen Insel, wenn man so
will, wenn man tatsächlich um die Grenzen hinaus
schaut, nicht nur in Europa. Es werden
neue Kernkraftwerke gebaut, und zwar genau
in Ländern des Südens, weil sie eine sichere
Energieversorgung brauchen.
Und sie wollen das auch günstig
haben. Es werden welche gebaut. In Bangladesch
beispielsweise, in den Vereinigten
Arabischen Emiraten wird das gemacht
und die werden sehr viel früher
klimaneutral sein als wir. Ich bin
gegen den Ausstieg aus der Kernenergie,
weil das unweigerlich zu mehr fossiler
Verbrennung führen wird, also mehr
Kohle und Gas. Und das heißt eine Milliarde
-Tonnen mehr CO2-Emissionen bis 2045.
-Also global betrachtet ist eigentlich die
Atomkraft auch der Niedergang. Jetzt
haben wir zum Beispiel gerade einen Konflikt
in der Ukraine, wo ich mir sage:
Na ja, gut, Atomkraftwerke sind weder
für Wetterextreme im Rahmen der Klimakrise
noch eben für mögliche Anschläge
ausgelegt. Das ist einfach nicht in der instabilen
geopolitischen Welt. Es ist
-einfach gefährlich.
-Das ist einfach nicht wahr. Also die
Kernkraftwerke sind für Unfälle
ausgelegt. Es war genau das Problem in Fukushima
gewesen, dass durch trefliches
Nachlassen der Behörden dort und von Tepco
auch die nicht für den schlimmsten
Fall vorgesorgt haben. Wenn dort zum Beispiel
auch wie in Deutschland die Kernkraftwerke
auf den schlimmsten Event, den es in 10000
Jahren gibt, vorbereitet gewesen
wären, dann wäre das nicht passiert,
was in Fukushima passiert ist, das muss
man sich klar machen. Das ist nicht
übertragbar, wie es Frau Kanzlerin
Merkel gemacht hat, auf Deutschland. Das ist
-einfach nicht so.
-Elia, was sind denn deiner Meinung nach
die schlimmsten Gefahren an Atomenergie?
Also einmal auf jeden Fall auch,
dass es keine Möglichkeit gibt,
die Abfälle sicher zu verwahren, denn
die strahlen eine Million Jahre und eine Million
Jahre kann es nirgendwo einen Ort
geben, wo die sicher sind. Es wird
im Zuge der Klimakatastrophe zu mehr stark
Wetterereignisse kommen, zum Beispiel
Überschwemmungen und so weiter.
Das bedeutet Lagerorte sind noch
mehr gefährdet, irgendwie kaputt zu gehen
oder nicht sicher zu sein. Und dazu
noch mal zu betonen, sind eben die Risiken
vom Uranabbau, wo niemand Bock drauf
hat. Also wer hat denn Lust irgendwo zu leben,
wo die Krebsraten mega nach oben
gehen? Wer hat Lust das Trinkwasser verunreinigt
wird? Also niemand. Und es gibt
ja Alternativen, erneuerbare Energien,
die all diese Problematiken
und Gefahren eben nicht mit.
Doch sie bringen es genauso, wenn sie genauso
extraktiv verschiedene Elemente
aus der Erde rausholen müssen das ist
nicht nur nichts Spezielles für Uran.
Das müssen wir allgemein
angehen. Wir müssen allgemein dafür sorgen,
dass überall wo, egal was geborgen
wird, dass das richtig gemacht wird. Und da gebe
ich vollkommen zu, wenn es da Missstände
gibt, müssen wir diese natürlich
bekämpfen. Aber das hat nichts
spezifisch mit Uran zu tun. Das passiert in vielen
-anderen Bereichen auch.
-Yasmine, denkst du denn, die Punkte, die
Elia gerade angesprochen hat, sind das Risiken,
die wir einfach eingehen müssen,
-um das Klima zu retten?
-Unter anderem, weil ich finde, die
Diskussion wirkt so ein bisschen,
als würden wir gerade darüber entscheiden,
ob wir neu in die Atomenergie
für die nächsten 200 Jahre einsteigen.
Der Atommüll ist da. Das ist ein Problem,
das es gibt und retrospektiv
auch die Debatte darum, wie sehr in Deutschland
geforscht wird. Also das wird
hier gerade schon angesprochen.
Die Forschungen in Atommüll, in Atom
prinzipiell in Deutschland ist viel
eingeschränkter als es im Ausland ist.
Und das führt dazu, dass die Debatte
hier auch bezüglich wie wir diesen Müll,
den wir übrigens haben und den wir schon
seitüber 60 Jahre haben, den Entfernt
auch in den Schatten stellen. Es koppelt
sich genau daran und ich glaube, das ist
das viel größere Problem, jetzt zu sagen,
wenn Atomkraftwerke wir reden jetzt
auch in Deutschland wirklich nur noch
von jetzt, glaube ich zwei Stück, die- Drei
Stück, die bis Ende des
Jahres abgeschaltet werden sollen,
ob die bleiben, weil die letzten sechs
haben zu über zehn Prozent der Versorgung
beigetragen. Und ich glaube, dass der Diskussionspunkt
eher ist: Streiten
wir uns über zehn Jahre weiter
Atommüll oder streiten wir uns über 1,5 Grad.
Ich finde der Druck, der in der Atom
Bewegung ausgeübt wird, warum ist
das nicht bei 1,5 Grad in der Kohle?
Ich würde mich sofort hinstellen, wenn Kohle
jetzt ausgeht und wir das komplett
transformieren können in was anderes,
das Geld. Das Geld, das wir ausgegeben
haben, um die Atomkraftwerke
herunterzufahren die letzten Jahre, wo hätte
das hingehen können? Das sind alles
-so Fragen, die eigentlich darauf zugehen.
-Also müssen wir deiner Meinung nach
einfach so ein bisschen den sauren
Apfel beißen, weil wir gerade nicht so viele
-Möglichkeiten.
-Ja, es ist ja gerade keine andere Lösung
da. Also die 40 Prozent Kohlekraft
und die CO2 Tonnen, die dadurch ausgestoßen
werden, sind ja das eigentliche
Problem, weil 1,5 Grad ist irreversibel.
-Und Atomkraft-
-Aber es gibt ja nicht nur zwei
Alternativen. Es gibt ja
nicht nur Kohle und Atomkraft
-zuverlässige Quellen gibt es wirklich
Atomkraft, Kohle und ja, Geothermal,
leider wohnen wir nicht in Island,
und Solar. Und Solar und Wind sind leider
in Deutschland noch und generell in der Welt
noch nicht zuverlässig und es gibt
nicht wirklich Speicherkapazitäten
davon. Wir sagen nicht die sind schlecht,
wir sagen einfach: wir sind noch
nicht bereit komplett auf die Renewables
-umzusteigen.
-Das halte ich für nicht zutreffend. Also
ich bin ehrlicherweise auch nicht
per se der Ansicht, dass man jetzt
vom Sicherheitsaspekt her Atomkraft
als die schlechteste Technologie darstellen
kann, weil ich glaube, dass die Kohlekraft
wesentlich mehr Tote verursacht.
Insofern aus Sicherheitsaspekten, wenn man
jetzt wirklich nur die beiden Alternativen
hätte, würde ich auch gar nicht per se
gegen die Atomkraft sein. Aber ich glaube,
es ist einfach gar nicht die beste
Möglichkeit, die wir haben. Und es löst
eine Abwägung aus, die gefährlich
ist. Denn wenn wir auch bestehende
Atomkraftwerke länger
laufen lassen wollen, dann müssen
sie auf Sicherheitsstandards und durch
Instandhaltungsmaßnahmen auf Level
bringen, was sehr viel Geld kostet.
Und dieses Geld wird es für den Ausbau
der Erneuerbaren fehlen. Insofern muss
man sich wirklich sehr sehr gut, sehr gut
abwägen und verstehen, dass das Geld
nur einmal ausgegeben werden kann.
Um die Energiewende wirklich zu schaffen
ist zum einen ein echtes Commitment,
eine komplette Entschlossenheit
notwendig. Das heißt, dass es auch kein Zurück mehr
gibt. Deshalb auch der Atomausstieg
feststehen sollte. Und zum Zweiten braucht
es, wie so oft auch schon
diskutiert wird, wirklich einen drastischen Abbau
der Regulierung und der Beschränkung,
wenn man Erneuerbare ausbauen möchte. Es ist
nicht zutreffend, dass die Atomkraft
eine gute Ergänzung zu Solar und Wind ist.
Das ist die technisch nicht. Von daher sollten
andere Technologien und andere
Lösungen forciert werden. Und es sollte
durch die geografische Diversifizierung
von Wind und Solar über ganz Europa,
vielleicht sogar mit Nordafrika hinweg,
dadurch eine Grundlast erzeugt
werden und eben nicht dadurch, dass man
-Atomkraftwerke laufen lässt.
-Armadeo, Yasmine, Alina, ihr seid alle
einen Schritt auf Ernesto
zugegangen. Warum?
Ja, also ich denke, dass man auf jeden
Fall nicht nur Kernenergie braucht.
Wir brauchen alle kohlenstoffarme
Energiequellen. Und ich denke, das lässt
sich am besten machen, wenn wir alles
auf einem ebenen Spielfeld sich entwickeln
lassen. Also das heißt, wir brauchen,
um möglichst schnell dahin zu kommen,
brauchen wir ganz einfach alle
drei. Zumindest jetzt im Moment, so lange
wir nichts anderes haben. Ob das in zehn,
zwanzig, dreißig Jahren eine andere
Situation sein wird, das kann ich nicht
sagen. Aber heute, nach dem heutigen Stand
ist es nicht so, dass wir alleine
mit Solar und Wind auskommen werden,
weil die ganzen Speicherkapazitäten
haben wir gar nicht. Wir haben sie nicht.
Wir werden Gas und Kohle brauchen.
Und man hat ja gesehen in den letzten Jahren
und 20 Jahren die beste
Versicherung für die Kohle und Gasindustrie ist,
die diese 100 Prozent Solar und Wind
Ideologie sag ich mal, gewesen,
weil sie konnten sich
weiterhin profilieren als der große Freund
-der erneuerbaren Energien.
-Ernesto es wurden jetzt schon ein paar Mal
die fehlenden
Speichermöglichkeiten, gerade bei erneuerbaren Energien,
angesprochen. Wie siehst du
das? Ist das ein großes Hindernis?
Das ist eine Herausforderung,
aber Atomkraft ist da keine gute Lösung.
Atomkraftwerke sind darauf ausgelegt,
die Deutschen beispielsweise, 400 Mal in ihrem
Lebenszyklus auf Null zu fahren.
Ungefähr. Das heißt zehnmal pro Jahr, über 40 Jahre.
Damit kann ich nicht gut modulieren
und ich kann eben nicht in einem Stromnetz,
in dem ich 80 Prozent bis 2030
Erneuerbare habe, genau diese Wind Veränderung
und die Sonnenstrahlung
ausgleichen. Das ist nicht die richtige
Ergänzungstechnologie. Darunter leidet
der Betrieb dann auch die Wirtschaftlichkeit,
weil Atomkraftwerke haben so hohe
Kapitalkosten, dass ich sie eigentlich
permanent laufen lassen muss, damit
sie von den Gestehungskosten, also wie viel
Cent pro Kilowattstunde kostet das überhaupt,
ansatzweise finanzierbar sind.
Aber so oder so müssen wir es ja
ausgleichen, so oder so muss die Energie
speicherbar sein, so oder so müssen
wir auf die Energie, die wir brauchen kommen.
-Wie machen wir das?
-Schritt 1 ist erst mal europäisch die
Erneuerbaren ausbauen und nicht jedes
Land für sich und eng vernetzen über den Ausbau
der Stromnetze. Denn ich habe, wenn ich gerade
in der Ostsee keinen Wind habe,
habe ich welchen in der Nordsee
oder im Atlantik. Und das gleiche gilt
für die Sonne, also einen sehr, sehr hohen
Ausgleichs- und Grundlastgrad erreicht man
allein durch eine geographische
Verkoppelung. Das zweite sind Speicher,
das dritte sind ja für eine gewisse
Weile auch noch Pica-Gaskraftwerke,
weil die einfach modulieren
können. Das fossile Brennstoffe und CO2.
Für eine gewisse Weile ja, weil die Atomkraft
das gar nicht leisten kann.
Die kann überhaupt nicht
bereitstehen, denn ich habe ein Grundlast Kraftwerk,
-das funktioniert nicht mit Solar und Wind.
-Aber wie viel Solar braucht man, um
wirklich die gleiche Energie zu erzielen.
Auch, wie viel Land brauchen wir, um so
viel Solar-Felder zu bauen und Solar,
wenn wir wissen in Vergleich oder Wind sagen
wir jetzt nicht, aber Solar verursacht
300 fach mehr Abfall als Atom. Wir können
wir können natürlich für die gleiche
Menge produzieren Energie produziert und das ist
schon so auch so ein Thema, worauf
wir gehen müssen. Wir müssen nicht immer so
sagen, auch grüne Energie
bedeutet kein CO2. Alles so super. Wir müssen
auch Sprechen über den Abfall von Schwermetallen,
dass Blei und Kobalt
heutzutage in Solaranlagen kommen
und zum Beispiel Japan heutzutage hat schon
ein Problem, in Zukunft all diesen Abfall
von Solaranlagen zu deponieren. Also
-das ist schon so ein großes Problem.
-Eines muss ich noch mal sagen zu der
Argumentation Wir können es ja
europäisch lösen, aber die anderen europäischen
Ländern machen eben nicht den deutschen
Kurs. Das ist wirklich isoliert
-in der ganzen Welt.
-Die Klimakrise ist jetzt und nicht in zehn
Jahren. Aber der Bau von neuen
Atommeiler, der dauert so lange. Und die aktuellen
Meiler weiterlaufen zu lassen, das halte
ich für lebensgefährlich, weil einfach
die ganze Rohrleitungen
korrodieren. Irgendwann haben wir den GAU
auch hierzulande und ich möchte
nicht warten, dass es zu spät wird.
Yasmine, was sagst du dazu, dass die Klimakrise
jetzt ist und eben nicht
in zehn Jahren und der Bau
aber lange dauert?
Ich würde für die Diskussion gerne
einen realpolitischen Aspekt einwerden.
Wir können hier- Es geht hier gar
nicht drum, ob Idealismus falsch ist.
Meiner Meinung nach können wir sofort
das ganze Land pflastern mit Solar. Darum geht
es mir gar nicht. Sondern, es gibt
realpolitische Gegebenheiten. Das heißt,
wer regiert, wer hat welche Pläne und wie regiert
das Ausland? Und der Kohleausstieg
ist nicht auf ein Datum festgelegt.
Das ist der schlimmste Skandal meiner Meinung
nach. Energiepolitik in den letzten
Jahren gegeben hat, dass wir nicht wissen,
wann die Kohle aus ist. Wir wissen
nicht, ob wir 1,5 Grad schaffen. Das würden
wir nämlich dann wissen. Das ist der viel
wichtiger Punkt. Das heißt, da gibt
es keine Debatte darum, was schön
wäre, sondern was passiert?
Und wenn wir Ausfälle haben, kriegen
wir trotzdem von den französischen Nachbarn
Atomstrom und wir kriegen aus Polen
auch Kohlestrom, wenn es vereinzelte Ausfälle
gibt. Und wenn das in Zukunft- Wenn wir jetzt
sozusagen Kohle nicht reduzieren
und die Erneuerbaren nicht so schnell
ausgebaut werden, weil wir in Deutschland
Stichwort Bürokratisierung ein riesiges
Problem haben, weil sich Parteien
und Kommunen sehr querstellen gegen bestimmte
Maßnahmen, dann kommen wir damit
nicht hinterher, auch wenn das Geld
da ist. Das heißt, wie gehen
wir mit der Situation um, wenn wir eine Strom
Knappheit kommen, wenn es teurer
-wird, obwohl wir alle wissen-
-und an der Stelle muss man noch sagen,
dann ist es doch notwendig Druck
auszuüben und zu sagen: Doch es ist möglich,
jetzt erneuerbare Energien
konsequent auszubauen, anstatt zu sagen- Aber hat
es funktioniert in den letzten 20
Jahre? Die Kommunen kriegen das nicht so gut hin.
Blöd gelaufen. Okay, dann
lassen wir das und machen Atomstrom.
Wir wollen es doch jetzt seit 20
Jahren, wo sind wir denn eigentlich? 20 Jahre
massive Investitionen hier. Wir sind
jetzt dabei immer noch bei CO2-Emissionen,
die fünfmal so hoch sind wie Frankreich,
was die Elektrizität angeht, fünfmal so
hoch. Und Deutschland wird vermutlich
da sein in zehn Jahren, wenn es gut geht,
wo Frankreich schon vor 20 Jahren
gewesen ist. Das muss man einfach auch sehen.
Also das heißt, so einfach ist es nicht.
Man baut nur erneuerbare Energien aus,
ohne zu gucken, ob das jetzt
Speicherbedarf gibt oder nicht.
Und wenn das Wetter einfach nicht
so gut ist, dann haben wir ein Problem.
Da brauchen wir ein Backup und im Moment
ist dieser Backup Kohle und Gas.
Und wenn jetzt das weitergeht
mit dieser Gas Knappheit, heißt es,
dass der Kohleausstieg noch
weiter in die Zukunft verlegt werden wird.
Aber um hier auch mal auf diese Idee
zu kommen von, dass sich der Wind,
der an der Ostsee fehlt, dann zum Beispiel
durch den Atlantik ausgleicht,
auch in Bezug auf die EU Taxonomie, ist
es einfach keine gute Strategie, jetzt Atom
und Gas auszubauen. Gas ist
auch extrem klimaschädlich. By the way.
Sondern es muss überall erneuerbare
Energien ausgebaut werden und dann müssen
sich Länder vernetzen und müssen sich
eben gegenseitig mit erneuerbaren und nicht
gefährlichen Technologien aushelfen,
anstatt jetzt irgendwie den Klimawandel
krass nach vorne zu treiben. Wie wäre
denn das Szenario, wenn wir jetzt beim Plan
bleiben und wir sagen Ende
2022, Ende diesen Jahres geht das letzte
Atomkraftwerk vom Netz? Was passiert
dann? Das wird dann passieren, dass wir noch
viel länger an Kohle und Gas
hängenbleiben. Und deswegen bin
ich gegen die Aufnahme von Gas in die Taxonomie.
Das ist ganz klar. Das ist CO2
emittierend und auch schädlich.
Aber wie die Forschungseinrichtungen
der Europäischen Union auch festgehalten
hat, ist, Kernenergie genauso
auf der gleichen Ebene zu stellen
wie Solar und Wind. Beide haben Vorteile,
beide haben Nachteile und das Beste,
was wir tun können, ist, alle kohlenstoffarme
Energiequellen zusammen zu nutzen, um den Klimawandel
möglichst schnell zu bremsen.
Und wenn wir das nicht schaffen, kann
ich nur sagen: Ich hoffe, dass die anderen
das kapiert haben und das tun.
Ist das nicht eigentlich ein absolutes
Totschlagargument gegen Gas, dass Atomkraft
nicht, also nicht CO2 frei ist,
aber sehr viel CO2 ärmer? Sollte
das nicht eindeutig dafür sprechen?
Ich will weder Kohle noch Atom noch
Gas. Aber irgendwas müssen wir machen ja gar
nicht stellen. Aber ist das nicht
eine Utopie? -energieeffizienter sein?
Können wir uns unseren Konsum
wechseln? Und ich engagiere mich für die Umwelt
nicht nur- Ich will keine Techno
Lösungen. Wir müssen auch ein System Change
herbeirufen. Das bedeutet, wir müssen
anders leben, anders konsumieren,
weil einfach die Erdressourcen begrenzt
sind. Und das ist sowohl der Fall für Uran
als auch für die diversen
fossilen Energien. Und ich möchte auch noch
einwerfen, dass Atomkraft ist auch nicht
komplett CO2 frei, insbesondere nicht,
wenn man den gesamten Zyklus mit berechnet,
zum Beispiel den Uran-Bergbau
mitrechnet, den Bau und was auch nicht
mal in den offiziellen Berechnungen drin ist,
ist ein Beispiel, wie CO2 intensiv
das Thema Endlagerung sein wird. Atommüll,
da wissen wir noch nicht wohin. Ich sehe
das wie ein Flugzeug ohne Landebahn.
-Lasst euch gerne Ausreden.
-Aber wenn wir, wie die Regierungen im
Moment wollen, das tief lagern
wollen, dann braucht es wieder sehr viel Beton,
sehr viel CO2. Das heißt,
so einfach ist es auch nicht.
Genau das ist die Kernfrage: Wohin mit dem Atommüll?
Wir haben Lösungen und es gibt
Länder, die das schon haben. Und die haben
es auch kostengünstig gemacht.
Zum Beispiel Finnland hat ihre Lösung
mit zweieinhalb Milliarden bis dreieinhalb
Milliarden, da habe ich verschiedene
Zahlen gelesen, aber die sind wesentlich
unter dem, was hier immer wieder
behauptet wird mit mehr stelligen, doppelt stelligen
Millionen Zahlen hier in Deutschland.
Das ist nicht der Fall. Das Problem ist
lösbar, wenn nur der politische Wille
und da komme ich noch mal zurück. Da ist
und das war in Deutschland nicht der Fall.
Man hat ein eine Verbindung gesetzt
zwischen: Wir müssen aussteigen,
sonst machen wir bei der Atommüll Frage nicht
mit. Das war das Problem gewesen
und deswegen sind wir noch an der Stelle,
-wo wir vor 20, 30 Jahren waren.
-Man erzählt uns schon seit 50 Jahren, dass
man da eine Lösung für Atommüll hat.
Nein, ist es nicht. Die diversen Versuche,
das gegeben hat, zum Beispiel in den USA,
in Granit wurde das eingebuddelt, da gab
es schon Unfälle und Austritt von Radioaktivität.
Plutonium war plötzlich
messbar an der Oberfläche. Nein, es gibt
kein sicheres Endlager. Tut mir leid.
Cecil sagt, sie möchte keine Kohle,
sie möchte kein Gas und sie möchte auch kein
Atomkraft. Was sagst du, Alina? Ist das überhaupt
realistisch? Also meiner Meinung
nach ist es heutzutage nicht
realistisch. Also wir können jetzt nicht ein Blackout
in der Mitte Europas haben, weil keine
Ahnung im Februar einfach keine Sonne
scheint und kein Wind bläht. Also
idealistisch- Ich verstehe warum so,
wir sollen eigentlich auch unseren
Konsum reduzieren, aber wir wohnen so
in einer Gesellschaft und wir haben so
ein Industriebedarf, Wirtschaftsbedarf, wo man
nicht einfach so idealistisch
reingehen kann, aber da muss man dann das alles
realistisch betrachtet. Also wo kommt
dieser Bedarf her? Also ist es wirklich
notwendig, dass so viel produziert
wird, dass so viel konsumiert wird? Und da muss
man ganz klar sagen Nein, es ist
nicht notwendig. Also wir müssen einfach
anfangen, dieses Wachstumsdogma und dieses profitorientierte
Handeln zu verändern,
hin zu einem füreinander
sorgenden Handeln, zu einem Mittel,
also ökologischem Handeln, anstatt
diesen Planeten auszubeuten, uns gegenseitig
auszubeuten. Und ja, im Prinzip
ein zerstörerisches Gesellschaftssystem
aufrechtzuerhalten. Yasmine,
du bist ein Schritt zurückgegangen.
Ja, dieses sollte und könnte geht mir
ein bisschen auf den Keks. Und das ist das,
was in dieser Debatte immer wieder
passiert. Nein, diese Gesellschaft wird
sich nicht zu hundert Prozent
umdrehen, nein, es ist ein klares Nein, es wird
nicht passieren. Dafür gibt es nicht
genug Bewegung, dafür gibt es nicht genug Leute,
die so wählen. Und ich kann auch sagen,
selbst aus Hintergrundgesprächen
mit hochrangigen Grünen, die wissen,
dass es jetzt knapp wird- Es ist nicht so,
dass man jetzt für Atom ist, aber dass man
das in der Öffentlichkeit sagen würde,
das ist schon gerade eine Grenze.
Und wenn wir die politische Landschaft
in Deutschland komplett anschauen,
ist die eine Hälfte der Wähler definitiv
konservativ, liberal oder gar rechts.
Das heißt, diese Mehrheit für den absoluten
Wandel, der in einer linken oder grünen
Ideologie gewünscht ist, egal ob man
das gut findet oder nicht, er wird
nicht passieren. Das heißt, was machen wir jetzt
damit? Weil wir wissen, dass 1,5
Grad kommt. Und das ist ja der Konsens,
den wir zumindest zu sechst gerade
haben, was ja eigentlich schön ist, weil das ja
selten passiert. Wie schaffen wir denn,
dass es jetzt passiert, dass wir wissen,
wir können uns erst mal versichern,
dass wir Kohle abschalten? Ich glaube,
meine größte Angst ist- Weil wie gesagt,
dieser Atommüll ist da, der ist
da und wird es auch noch ein paar
Jahre geben. Und in Deutschland werden
auch keine neuen mehr gebaut
werden. Da geht es auch darum, wie gehen
wir mit dem EU-Ausland um?
Die werden weiterhin bauen. Werden
wir da Partnerschaften haben? Werden
wir von den Strom beziehen, wenn es bei uns
knapp wird? Wird es die nächste
Regierung und die jetzige schaffen,
dass wir Erneuerbare so ausbauen,
dass uns darauf verlassen können, wenn die so
in Forschung investieren, dass wir sagen
können, die Speicherkapazitäten für Solar
sind irgendwann da 2029? Und das sind
die Fragen, mit denen beschäftigen müssen.
Ernesto, was muss denn deiner Meinung
nach jetzt konkret passieren? Weil wir haben
das ja jetzt ist jetzt schon immer
wieder aufgekommen, dass wir schneller
mit den erneuerbaren Energien
vorankommen, weil es wurde ja schon oft genug gesagt,
-wir kommen nicht schnell genug voran.
-Absolut. Und das ist mir auch wichtig zu
sagen: die Ziele, die wir haben,
80 Prozent Erneuerbare bis 2030
in Deutschland, auch sehr hohe
Ziele EU-weit, die sind nicht unrealistisch,
die sind auch jetzt noch zu schaffen.
Sie sind sehr ambitioniert. Nur ich habe
die große Sorge, dass wenn man jetzt
auf einmal dieses Atomkraft Thema aufmacht,
noch mal ein weiteres Argument
geliefert wird, um eben die Veränderungen,
die notwendig sind, nicht zu tätigen.
Und die Veränderung sind keine großen.
Es kostet nicht viel Geld. Es muss
in Deutschland jetzt beispielsweise
bundesweit standardisiert werden, wie man
Solaranlagen Windkraftwerke anmelden kann.
Das muss automatisiert erfolgen,
zum Beispiel über die Bundesnetzagentur,
dass nicht jeder Netzbetreiber in jeder
Stadt selber entscheidet, wie die Prozesse
sind. Das sind relativ
einfache Entscheidung zum Zentralisieren
und zum Entbürokratisierung. Und das wird
dann die die Energiewende entfesseln.
Und wir sehen es auch schon, wir sehen
das in bestimmten Segmenten. Und ich glaube
und denke schon, dass eine politische
Veränderung jetzt da ist. Vielleicht nicht
so groß, wie man sich die gewünscht
hätte, aber eben doch, dass da Schritte kommen,
von denen ich auch glaube,
dass sie helfen.
Und trotzdem ist es ja bis hierhin
noch nicht so passiert,
dass wir diese Diskussion hier
gerade nicht führen müssten. Ist es also
eine Frage des politischen
Willens oder woran liegt's? Absolut, es hat
der politische Willen gefehlt. Wir haben
in den letzten 10, 14 Jahren keine
politische Mehrheit dafür
gehabt. Es wurden Gesetze gemacht,
das Erneuerbare-Energien-Gesetz.
Die Novellen, die es in den letzten Jahren
gab, hatten sehr, sehr viele
Fallstricke, die dafür gesorgt haben, dass auch junge
Unternehmen, wie unseres, nicht
in der Geschwindigkeit wachsen konnte,
wie es eigentlich vom Markt gewünscht
ist. Und ich glaube schon, dass das relativ
leicht zu entfesseln ist und ich würde
auch noch mal, ist mir schon wichtig,
auch widersprechen, alle anderen machen
es anders. Das stimmt nicht. Es gibt einzelne
Länder, die auf Atomkraft
setzen. Natürlich ist Frankreich prominent.
Es gibt im Baltikum, in Osteuropa
einige Länder. Aber eigentlich ist das Thema rein
marktwirtschaftlich an ganz vielen
Orten auch tot. Es finden sich auch kaum private
Investoren dafür, dass es neue
Kraftwerke sind viel zu teuer und rechnen sich nicht
gegenüber den Strompreisen an der Börse.
Deshalb ist das nicht ein einzelner Weg,
den wir gehen. Spanien, Italien, ganz
viele puschen bei den Erneuerbaren massiv.
Yasmine, du hast es vorhin schon
mal kurz angesprochen, dass du auch viele
Politiker*innen zu tun hast, dass du
auch weißt aus Hintergrundgesprächen,
dass Leute zum Beispiel von den Grünen
sagen: Ja, ehrlich gesagt würde
das auch Sinn machen, wenn man zum Beispiel
Atomkraft wieder in Erwägung
ziehen würde. Was glaubst du denn ist
da das Problem? Also geht es um Festhalten
an dem Atomausstieg und um Glaubwürdigkeit?
Oder geht es tatsächlich
-um Überzeugungen? Woran liegt es da?
-Ich glaube, es ging mal um Überzeugung und
jetzt ist es so ideologiebasiert,
dass wir dieses Problem haben, dass man keine
Meinung haben kann, ohne automatisch
ideologisiert zu werden. Und ich glaube,
dass das in der Bevölkerung
prinzipiell diese Diskussion nicht so angekommen ist,
wie wir das jetzt gerade wollen, weil es nämlich
sehr von oben herab ist und so
ideologisiert ist. Das heißt, die einen
verbinden automatisch mit Erneuerbaren:
Die Grünen wollen uns ein Windrad vor die Haustür
ballern und die anderen verbinden,
damit Atomkraft: die CDU ist schuld,
dass wir die Klimakrise haben und abschaffen.
-Also sozusagen diese zwei Extreme.
-Die Grünen sind ja aus der
Anti-Atom-Bewegung mit entstanden.
Würdest du sagen, die stehen sich jetzt in ihrer
jetzigen Position mit ihrer, wie du
gesagt hast, um dich zu zitieren, Ideologie
-im Weg?
-Nein, ich glaube, die sind einfach- Das
ist der Unterschied
zwischen aktivistischen Bewegungen,
Klimabewegung und Realpolitik.
Wenn man in einer Regierungsebene ankommt,
wie die Grünen es jetzt final, nicht
in der Schröder Ära, sind, sondern jetzt
mit der FDP und SPD, merkt man
einfach, welche Kompromisse man eingehen muss,
-wenn es bestimmte schlimme Szenarien gibt.
-Was denkt ihr denn? Sollten sich die
Parteien dieser Frage Atomkraft ja
oder nein noch mal stellen, bevor Ende 2022
die letzten Atomkraftwerke in Deutschland
vom Netz gehen? Schreibt es mal
in die Kommentare. Du bist gerade
einen Schritt auf Yasmine zu gegangen. Wieso?
Genau weil gerade bei dem Punkt,
einmal Unterschied von sozialen Bewegungen
und von Parteipolitik und da eben
Kompromisse gemacht werden müssen,
und auch zum Punkt: Wir brauchen
eine große Veränderung wollte ich mal stark
machen, dass ich der Meinung
bin, dass ein großer Wandel möglich ist
und dass der vor allem von der Straße
kommt. Und dass auch diese Idee:
wir müssen Profitorientiertheit
und wir müssen Ausbeutung als Grundlage
von unserer Gesellschaft überdenken
und müssen wir verändern, sowohl um soziale
Krisen als auch um ökologische
Krisen aufzuhalten und zu stoppen.
Das ketten sich auch Mütter an Atomkraftwerke
zurzeit. Das möchte
auch nur ganz kurz mal sagen: Es gibt
nicht die eine Klimabewegung. Es gibt
auch Menschen, die für Atomkraft auf die Straße
gehen. Es gibt auch diese berühmte
Szene auf der FFF-Demo, wo eine Atomkraft
Aktivistin, die dafür ist, die mit FFF
eigentlich demonstrieren wollte,
wurde weggezerrt und ausgebuht und wo man
auch wieder sagen muss, was gibt es dafür
Hierarchien? Wie ist unser Miteinander
in der Lösungsfindung?
1,5 Grad ist unser Ziel.
Elia du nickst, gehst oder ein klein
wenig Schritt auf Yasmine zu?
Nur in diesem Punkt? Also ich würde
sagen, ich habe gerade so ein bisschen- Ich habe
gerade genickt, weil ich sagen
würde: Ja, ich finde, die Art und Weise,
wie wir miteinander umgehen, ist
auf jeden Fall ein großer Punkt. Wie gehen
wir zwischenmenschlich miteinander
um? Wollen wir wirklich in Konkurrenz
miteinander stehen, um die meisten
Profite zu machen? Weil das zerstört
diesen Planeten und das zerstört
irgendwo auch uns. Das finde ich sehr, sehr schön
und sehr idealistisch. Wir stehen
jetzt vor einer Krise. Wir sehen, was jetzt
passiert in der Ukraine mit Russland.
Wir müssen nicht vergessen, dass Deutschland
zum Beispiel sein Gas zu 30 Prozent
aus Russland bekommt. Jetzt haben wir gehört,
das Scholz gesagt hat
Nordstream 2 aufhalten. Jetzt stehen
wir vor einer Energiekrise. Jetzt
können wir schön reden, wie es eigentlich in 10
Jahre sich entwickeln soll. Aber
was soll jetzt in den nächsten paar Jahren
passieren. Ich meine, wenn jetzt die Atomkraftwerke
jetzt alle ausgeschaltet
werden, woher kommt jetzt Gas? Also
das bedeutet, dass wir jetzt mehr von Kohle
und Gas abhängig werden von Gas ist
jetzt schwierig, weil wie gesagt, diese jetzt
ganz politische Frage auch, ob wir weiter
mit Russland verhandeln oder so,
-aber-
-Wir brauchen das Gas ja auch vor allem-
Also wir brauchen es zum Teil für Strom,
aber wir brauchen es ja vor allem
für Prozesse. Wir haben Industrie
Prozessen und wir brauchen es zum Heizen.
Da hilft uns die Atomkraft nicht.
Wenn wir jetzt aber die Atomkraftwerke nicht
ausschalten, dann können wir diese Energien
auch nutzen und ein bisschen
weiter von dieser Import von Gas
weggehen. Deutschland ist einer von großen Importeur
von Gas in Europa. Verstehst du
trotzdem dem Punkt, dass Gas gerade
in der aktuellen Situation, auch wenn man
mit Ländern wie Russland zusammenarbeitet,
eine politische Sackgasse werden
könnte und auch wenn man perspektivisch
in den nächsten 10, 20, 30, 40 Jahre
guckt, dann ist ja klar, wir werden immer
mehr Strom brauchen. Jetzt gerade
kommen wir in eine Situation, da kann man einfach
sagen: Nee, ciao, keinen Strom. Also
100 prozent. Ich glaube, die Idee, dass jetzt
importiertes Pipeline-Gas und auch überhaupt
Gas für uns eine tragende Säule
oder die tragende Säule in dem Energiemix
sein sollte, die habe ich nicht.
Ich glaube, dass Gasproblem ist ja vor allem
ein Wärme und auch Industrieproblem.
Wenn man sich den Strommix anschaut,
sind Gaskraftwerke wegen ihrer Flexibilität
wichtig, aber nicht wegen der Menge,
die sie liefern. Da spielen sie eine eher
-untergeordnete.
-Aber es geht jetzt konkret um die Frage
-der Zusammenarbeit mit Russland.
-Das ist für mich eine ganz andere Debatte,
weil da hilft die Atomkraft nicht,
das will ich damit sagen. Ich kann- Aber
was ist die Antwort darauf trotzdem,
ist ja die Frage- Ich glaube, dass wir beim
Gas schon viel früher hätten
diversifizieren müssen und dann sukzessiv
natürlich Gas auch durch Wasserstoff
ersetzen müssen. Aber ich glaube schon,
dass wir Flüssiggas brauchen und bereit
sein müssen, dafür ein bisschen Preis
zu zahlen. Wir haben uns bisher
politisch auch damals Fukushima- Zu der Zeit habe
ich auch auch mit einem
Energieunternehmen zu tun gehabt in meinem Job
als Unternehmensberater, da waren
damals die politischen Entscheidungen: Wir setzen
voll auf das Pipeline Gas und das halte
ich für einen Fehler. Ich glaube schon,
dass man diversifizierten Gasimporte
braucht, bis wir irgendwann kein Gas mehr
brauchen, sowohl in der Wärme,
weil wir auf Wärmepumpen sind und anderen
Technologien als auch beim Strom
selbst. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass wir auf Gas
verzichten können und Atomkraftwerke
werden uns dabei nicht helfen.
Für die nächsten 10, 15 Jahre.
Insofern brauchen wir sowieso Gas und müssen
das Problem anders
lösen, nämlich durch Airnergy.
Wenn wir sagen Ja, natürlich, brauchen
wir noch Gas und so. Wir brauchen die ganze so
verschiedene Energiequellen, um wirklich
unser Netzwerk stabil zuzulassen und damit
eine steigende- In Deutschland steigt
ständig der Energie Konsum und ich meine,
es ist wirklich einfach unmöglich,
hier jetzt einfach zu sagen: Hey wir,
wir schalten jetzt Atomkraftwerke und dann
werden wir nur auf die grüne Energie
aufsteigen. Es wird jetzt nicht in den nächsten
15, 20 Jahren passieren. Es ist
einfach keine Möglichkeit wirklich
auf grüne Energie umzusteigen. Bedeutet wir-
Ist Atomkraft die Lösung? Die Antwort
ist Nein. Es ist eine Lösung. Also ich bin,
wo ich einverstanden bin, ist: Gas ist
eine Sackgasse. Wo ich einverstanden bin,
ist, die Politik muss handeln und das ist
zu viel zu träge. Egal welche politische
Entscheidungen man trifft, bei den Erneuerbaren
ist es viel zu träge.
Wir sind in einem Punkt, wo wir politische
Entscheidungen treffen müssen. Wenn die eh
getroffen werden, dann will ich, dass die gegen die Atomkraft
getroffen werden.
Ich will, dass das Geld nicht in diesem Greenwashing,
in dieser Atomenergie geht,
sondern da, wo es auch richtig
sinnvoll investiert wird. Weil wir treffen
Entscheidungen in einer geopolitisch,
instabilen Lage. Und dann komme
ich auf Russland zurück, weil auch die Verbindung
zum Militär so nah ist.
Also geopolitisch ist das einfach ein Kochtopf,
der möglicherweise mit dem Druck
irgendwann explodieren wird.
Atomkraft kann dann nicht, das ist zu gefährlich.
Wir können doch nicht
Krieg spielen mit Atomkraft.
Wir haben, glaube ich alle- Es ist
uns allen klar geworden, dass dieses Thema
extrem komplex ist. Wir haben
über die Gefahren gesprochen, über Klima
und Generationengerechtigkeit, über
globale Ungerechtigkeit, über politische
Abhängigkeit. Deswegen lass uns jetzt
zum Abschluss noch mal bei der sozialen Lösung
für dieses Thema bleiben. Ist denn
Atomenergie für uns alle am günstigsten?
Nein, ich sage: Dieser Weg mit nur 100
Prozent erneuerbare Energien, das ist
das Problem. Erneuerbare Energien
sind nicht schlecht. Wir brauchen Solar,
wir brauchen Wind. Aber das Problem,
was wir in Deutschland hatten,
dass wir am Anfang zumindest 98, als diese Energiewende
eingeleitet worden ist,
ging es ja gar nicht um Klima. Es ging
um aus der Atomenergie auszusteigen.
Und das hat jetzt dazu geführt, dass wir im Prinzip
nur Atom durch Kohle ersetzt
oder Atom durch erneuerbare
Energien ersetzt haben, während Kohle und Gas
-munter weiter laufen konnten.
-Ernesto, du hattest das vorhin schon mal
quasi mit den Kosten angesprochen.
Wie siehst du das denn? Wäre Atomkraft
eine Lösung, eine sozial
gerechte Lösung für für die Stromfrage?
Über die nächsten fünf Jahre hinaus?
Nein, und das ist wirklich- Das ist mir
auch der wichtigste Punkt: Ich gucke
auch auf das Thema Energie,
auch wenn ich selber
Solarenergieunternehmen bin, sehr nüchtern
und als Volkswirt. Und es ist
so: ein abgeschriebenen Atomkraftwerk,
was da steht seit 30 Jahren.
Ja, das produziert Strom für 3 Cent
je Kilowattstunde. Das ist
günstig, aber nur solange ich das nicht neu
modernisieren muss oder neu bauen
muss. Ein neu gebautes Kernkraftwerk
oder ein aufwendig
modernisiertes, da bin ich bei 12 bis 20 Cent.
Alleine Börsenpreis plus die ganzen
Umlagen. Wenn wir sozial gerecht
sein wollen, dann müssen wir die Umlagen
reduzieren, wird jetzt ja teilweise
gemacht. Da müssen wir auf Erneuerbare
setzen, die sind am günstigsten. Und dann
müssen wir letztlich, also
wenn wir gucken, gerade Frankreich hat
um ein höhere Börsenpreise Strom als Deutschland,
bereits seit Wochen. Das hat
mit den Gestehungskosten zu tun.
Grenzkosten-Thema und da ist einfach
Atomkraft nicht die Lösung. Es ist
nicht günstig. Also gerade was die Kosten
angeht, muss ich wirklich
widersprechen. Das ist ja wirklich wieder ein deutscher
Tunnelblick, muss ich sagen.
Wenn man internationale Vergleiche sieht
und das hängt natürlich damit
zusammen, wie man das ausrechnet, läuft
ein Kernkraftwerk nur 35 Jahre wie in Deutschland
oder 60 oder 80 Jahre,
wie die Neuen geplant werden, dann
sieht die Rechnung komplett anders aus.
Wir könnten detailliert in alle
diese Berechnungen gehen,
was die Entstehungskosten angeht und was die Kosten
für die Endlagerung angeht.
Das sind alles Mythen, die wir seit
30, 40 Jahren hören. Wir sollten uns wirklich
mit den Fakten, wie sie heute
existieren, mit dem heutigen Stand der Technik uns
auseinandersetzen. Und die sieht
völlig anders aus. Das musste ich auch selber
-lernen.
-Ich glaube, es ist jetzt der richtige
Zeitpunkt, um zumindest mal zu versuchen,
zu den Kompromissen zu kommen und welche
zu finden. Das Ganze läuft jetzt so ab
Ich habe einen Kompromissvorschlag an euch
und zudem könnt ihr euch gleich
positionieren, mir sagen, was ihr davon
denkt und dann habt ihr Zeit auf eurem
Feld, um die Köpfe zusammen zu stecken
und einen Kompromissvorschlag an die andere
Seite zu wenden. Okay, kommen
wir zu meinem Kompromissvorschlag
für euch: was klar geworden ist: Wir kommen
nicht drum herum, in den einen
oder anderen sauren Apfel zu beißen,
zumindest auf dem Weg zu den erneuerbaren
Energien. Wir müssen uns öffnen,
auch in Deutschland, auch mit der Geschichte
unserer Anti-Atom-Bewegung
in Deutschland, für einen
ergebnisoffenen Diskurs über das Ja oder Nein zumindest
noch mal darüber zu sprechen. Da könnt
ihr jetzt gerne noch mal einen Schritt
auf mich zugehen. Stehenbleiben oder wie du
dich gerade zurück bewegst, Cecile.
Ihr stimmt mir zu. Cecile,
du hast dich zurück bewegt. Warum?
Es ist jetzt Zeit, dass die Politik
handelt. Es ist nicht mehr Zeit rum
zu eiern. Bin ich dafür oder dagegen?
Die Argumente sind auf dem Tisch. Wir haben
uns entschieden. Wir sind
gegen die Atomkraft. Deutschland hat
auch ein Teilausstieg beschlossen.
Das ist eine gute Sache, auch wenn er nicht
vollständig ist wegen der Brennstoffproduktion
in Lingen und Gronau.
Und das muss so weitergehen. Ich will
jetzt nicht mehr den Moment, dass wir noch
-darüber reden.
-Ich denke auch aus Pragmatismus wird es-
Es wäre fatal, wahrscheinlich,
sogar die Diskussion noch mal aufzumachen,
weil sie ablenkt von den Handlungsaufgaben.
Deshalb würde
ich sie nicht aufmachen, sondern wenn überhaupt,
dann würde ich sagen: Es sind
jetzt drei Kraftwerke noch am Netz.
Dann soll halt die Bundesnetzagentur sagen,
welche drei Kohlemeiler sie rausnimmt
und dafür sagen: Dafür lassen wir die drei
AKWs noch drei Jahre laufen. Dafür
sollte man aus meiner Sicht keine breite Debatte
-mehr an-
-Aber für die Entscheidung muss trotzdem
noch mal darüber gesprochen und das überhaupt
noch mal in Erwägung gezogen
-werden-
-Das heißt, es wird keine ergebnisoffene
Diskussion. Das wäre eine ganz
spitze Diskussion, die die Frage hätte: Sollen
wir jetzt Kohlemeiler XY rausnehmen,
um jetzt 10 Prozent CO2 herunterzufahren?
Sofort? Und dafür die noch 2 oder 3
Jahre laufen lassen? Dass wäre eine sehr spitze
Diskussion, eine ergebnisoffene
Diskussion, gibt es neue Erkenntnisse
und so weiter, würde uns massiv
ablenken. Wir sehen ja, wie lange wir brauchen
-und um überhaupt ins Handeln zu kommen.
-Bevor wir jetzt zu euren Kompromissen
kommen. Ganz kurz Yasmine, warum bist
du einen Schritt zurückgenagen
-zurückgegangen?
-Weil es hier nicht darum geht, dass wir
die komplette Diskussion noch mal
aufrollen. Aber zu sagen, dass würden
wir diese Debatte aufmachen,
wir vom Kernproblem ablenken, ist halt
auch falsch. Weil es geht darum,
dass man sagt: Das Wichtigste ist 1,5 Grad
und Kohle ist das Problem. Das heißt,
diese Nischendebatte Atom ist
auch ein Hinweis darauf, dass 1,5
Grad durch Kohle gelöst werden müssten.
Also das ist eine Teil Diskussion
dessen, wenn man alle mit einbezieht. Das ist
nämlich nicht nur eine grüne
Perspektive, sondern die gesamte Perspektive braucht
-auch diesen Atom-Diskussionspunkt.
-Deswegen werde ich euch jetzt kurz einmal
die Köpfe zusammenstecken lassen auf jedem
Feld und ihr könnt euch jetzt einen
Kompromissvorschlag für die andere
Seite überlegen und versuchen
wir ihr die anderen überzeugen könnt
einen Schritt auf euch zuzugehen. Mal gucken
-ob das klappt.
-Kann ich den Polen, kann ich den Finnen
-sagen, was sie tun sollen?
-Wie ist das denn mit den Erneuerbaren? Wie
schnell kann es ausgebaut werden?
Okay, wir merken, das Thema ist wahnsinnig
komplex. Es muss super
viel bedacht werden, wenn man sich
entweder für oder gegen Atomenergie
entscheidet. Und hier werden gerade
fleißig Kompromisse überlegt. Was ist
denn euer Kompromiss, nachdem ihr diese Sendung
hier geschaut habt, schreibt
es gerne mal in die Kommentare.
Das heißt, wir werden es nicht
schaffen Kohle in 2025 abzuschalten.
Keine Einmischung ins EU-Ausland-
Und im Ausland überhaupt.
Genau. Dann würde ich sagen: Ich fange
an mit eurem Kompromissvorschlag,
mit dem gelben Feld. Was habt ihr euch
überlegt? Also wir haben festgestellt,
es herrscht Einigkeit darin,
dass wir einen gemeinwohlorientierteres
Gesellschaftssystem bräuchten und dass wir alle
die Klimakrise aufhalten möchten.
Und deswegen ist unser Vorschlag
immer noch erneuerbare Energien ausbauen,
am Gemeinwohl orientiertes
Gesellschaftssystem und Energiesystem
und das Energiesystem
vergesellschaften. Ihr könnt also jetzt gerne einen Schritt
auf das andere Feld zugehen,
stehenbleiben, einen Schritt nach hinten
-gehen.
-Der erste Teil wäre okay, aber wir müssen
zumindest die drei und ich würde
sogar sagen sechs Kernkraftwerke,
wenn wir sie wieder in Stand
bringen können, laufen lassen,
bis wir zu dem Zeitpunkt gekommen
sind, wo andere Optionen besser sind.
-Yasmine siehst du das auch so?
-Ne ich find nen anderen Ansatz- Also
prinzipiell finde ich, dass der Kompromiss
sehr viel Idealismus ist,
bis auf eine Sache, die Verstaatlichung.
Prinzipiell ja, in dem Rahmen,
in dem es möglich ist, in der politischen
Gegebenheit. Es ist ja nicht was,
was überall in jedem Bundesland
einfach so easy zur Diskussion steht. Das heißt
prinzipiell ja, aber nur da, wo es auch politisch
so möglich ist, je nachdem,
wo sich dafür Mehrheiten finden und wo so
gewählt wird, dass die politischen Akteure
-so handeln.
-Alina, was denkst du? Ja, also theoretisch
würde ich das unterschreiben,
aber praktisch sehe ich da, dass es keine
wirklich praktischer Art von Kompromiss
ist. Was wird jetzt in den nächsten 5
Jahren passieren? Okay, dann würde ich euch
jetzt gerne euern Kompromissvorschlag
-bitten.
-Unserer ist ein bisschen- Also der lehnt
sich noch mal an dieser Debatte um die drei
Laufenden an. Es geht erstens darum,
dass die drei laufen dürfen,
solange der jeweilige Prozentsatz, den Kohle
verursacht, zurückgefahren wird. Das heißt,
dass was diese drei AKW weiterhin
produzieren würden, je nachdem wie die Erneuerbaren
aufholen, das bei der Kohle
einzusparen. Und das ist ein gesetztes
Ziel gibt für einen CO2 Ausstieg
finanziell, dass man weiß, dass wenn man
da aussteigt, dass das Geld,
weil wir auch eben über
Arbeitsplätze gesprochen haben, reinvestiert wird,
so dass alle Menschen, die in der Kohleenergie
arbeiten, rübergesetzt werden
können, versichert. Also da geht
es ja auch um Arbeitsplätze und soziale
Absicherung, dass dieser Transfer
in die andere Energiebranche passiert
und dass wir sozusagen uns trotzdem
mit diesen Atomkraftwerken, die laufen,
noch etwas absichern, bis diese nicht
mehr instand gehalten werden können.
Okay, was sagt ihr? Geht er einen
Schritt auf die andere Seite zu? Das war aber
-nicht mal ein Zentimeter, Ernesto.
-Ja, es waren auch sehr viele Aspekte drin,
wo viele jetzt- Ich hab auch nicht
alle ganz verarbeiten können, aber auch viele
für mich nicht sehr sinnvoll und plausibel
klangen. Gerade dieses Thema
Transferleistung. Ich glaube da ist
mehr als genug gemacht, auch im Verhältnis
zur Größe der Kohlebranche. Ich glaube,
das ist nicht das Thema. Wie gesagt,
aus meiner Sicht diese drei
Kraftwerke zu tauschen für zwei bis drei Jahre,
sofern das überhaupt praktikabel ist,
aber für mich aus meiner Sicht zwei bis drei
Jahre, und zu sagen dafür schalten wir sofort
in gleichem Maße Kohle ab, um jetzt
einen großen CO2 Effekt zu haben.
Jetzt in 22 und 23, das ist das Einzige,
-was ich für sinnvoll halte.
-Ich finde, dass diese Debatte, weil wir
auch darüber gesprochen haben, wie präsent
das Thema sein sollte und wir auch darüber
gesprochen, und es war sehr viel
Reflexion über die Debatte in der Debatte, das hat
mir sehr gut gefallen und ich bezeichne
mich immer sehr gern als Realistin.
Ich weiß auch, dass das eine Komfortzone
ist, aber auch einerseits mein Pessimismus
ist und ich glaube da noch mal
immer wieder dieses Anstoßen von: Es gibt
dieses Ideal und Ideale kann man
umsetzen, wenn es nur genug politische Kraft gibt,
dem entgegengesetzt, was man
selber glaubt und, dass manchmal sozusagen
diesen positiven Gedanken, dass es könnte,
zuzulassen in der eigenen Bewertung.
Das fand ich ganz gut. Ich glaube,
dass ich trotzdem Realistin bleiben werde.
Aber das immer wieder mitzunehmen und das noch
mal dazu zu stoßen und vielleicht
mit etwas mehr Elan in die nächste
Debatte zu gehen, das kann ich für mich persönlich
-mitnehmen.
-Ja, dazu kann ich auf jeden Fall sagen:
Ich bin auf jeden Fall
Idealistin bei uns beiden oder auch generell
ein idealistischer Mensch. Und ich glaube
auch, dass es das in diesen Debatten
auf jeden Fall auch braucht. Genauso
wie es auch zum Beispiel in Form von dir,
Menschen braucht, die ganz klar
sagen: Okay, so sieht's politisch aus.
Und das und das und das ist so
der Zustand, in dem wir uns befinden.
Und ich glaube, das ist auch voll
wertvoll, dann eben zusammen zu kommen
und eben Realistinnen und Idealistinnen
dann zu haben und dann gemeinsam
zu schauen: Okay, was könnte unser idealistisches
Ziel sein oder was ist es?
Und wie können wir da irgendwie im Hier
und Jetzt hinkommen? Ich danke euch
trotzdem vielmals für die Diskussion.
Wirklich. Das hat sehr sehr, sehr viel
Spaß gemacht und ich wünsche euch
noch einen schönen Abend. Danke. Dankeschön!
Wenn euch diese Folge 13 Fragen
gefallen hat, dann lasst doch hier gerne ein Abo
für den Kanal da, hier oben gibt
ein weiteres Video von 13 Fragen und hier
unten ein weiteres Video zum Thema.